and initiate sequencing
[Music]
and memories are made of live what is
this place
I'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed at rst we'd
rebuild the most important assets in the
US military soldiers like yourself
you're the first who we've successfully
managed to bring back but improved
enhanced with the technology in your
veins you have an army inside you that
will not only make you stronger it will
heal you installation
now tell me do you remember anything
[Music]
where you going I've got unfinished
business
I'm the man who murdered my wife and
kill off
oh that's not good
alright sundown
and initiate sequence
okay who is the next target for
elimination
these are made of blue tell me do you
remember anything
do I know you guys I don't think so
I've been manipulating you what you
think is real
sometimes ain't and initiate sequence
[Music]
control
sure about that
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
that is absolutely fantastic
I feel like I just heard this so they
claim assembly people
[Music]
you